[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEVIN VLK: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Kevin Vlk with
the Google team.
And here we are in sunny
LA at YouTube Space.
How awesome is this
space, eh, guys?
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
So this full
production facility--
we're really, really
excited here because we're
doing something brand
new that we haven't
done in Talks at Google before.
We're doing a YouTube
360 degree live stream.
So we're live right now across
the world and these two cameras
that you see here
are 360 degrees.
For you guys
watching online, what
we're going to be
doing here today
is interviewing the
cast of "Finding Dory."
We're going to bring them
up here in just a second.
For you guys watching
online-- if you're
watching on your mobile device,
just take your phone, just
look around in
complete 360 degrees.
Then we've got some fun
stuff here in the back.
You can look around the
production facility.
And then if you're on
desktop, just take your mouse,
click the video, move it
around, and that's it.
All right, are we
ready to meet the cast?
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
All right, let's bring them out.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the voice cast
and creative team behind
Disney Pixar's "Finding Dory."
[MUSIC] [APPLAUSE]
Alrighty, welcome guys.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Hello.
ANDREW STANTON: Hello.
KEVIN VLK: Thanks so
much for coming here.
So, "Finding Dory,"
out June 17th,
thank you guys all
for being here.
Ellen, welcome.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Hi.
KEVIN VLK: So this
is a movie completely
about your character, Dory.
And you've been--
ELLEN DEGENERES: There are
other characters, as well.
KEVIN VLK: Right.
Thank you.
But-- so your-- go ahead.
ALBERT BROOKS: I don't
know, I just found that out.
ELLEN DEGENERES: I'm Dory.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN VLK: And so-- but
you were a huge cheerleader
for this film for
years on your show.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Thank
god I had a show.
We would not be sitting here
had I not had a talk show.
True statement.
It's true.
KEVIN VLK: Talk
about intimidation.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Yeah.
He finally called
and said uncle.
He's like, all
right, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
ANDREW STANTON: She
said, I was just kidding.
That's what she said.
ELLEN DEGENERES: I was like,
no, I'm not interested.
No, it was started as-- I
seriously wanted a sequel.
I was like, they
make sequels for
every other successful film.
We won an Academy Award,
for crying out loud,
so where's the sequel?
And then, it just
got to be a joke.
And then I just gave up.
And I was just--
well, I'm just going
to keep going
because it's funny.
But then it worked out.
KEVIN VLK: And then
13 years later.
So Andrew, you brought
this back 13 years later.
So when did that idea-- besides
Ellen pushing it-- come to you?
ANDREW STANTON: You know,
when you make these movies,
you see them so many times.
So I'd seen "Finding
Nemo" about 100 times
before 2003 even finished.
So you just stop watching.
And about eight years
later, it was 2011,
they wanted to put it out in 3D.
They put me in a
theater and I watched it
like an audience member for
the first time in a long time.
And I walked out so
worried about Dory.
I was just like, she's going
to forget Marlin and Nemo,
she won't know how to get back.
And I don't know
where she's from.
And I think she's got
abandonment issues
that I know about as a writer.
So suddenly, it just all
started to bubble up after that.
KEVIN VLK: It's unbelievable.
And it's a wonderful
film, I've seen it.
It's absolutely--
ALBERT BROOKS: By the way,
as long as you're here.
Make the third
one before we die.
ANDREW STANTON: Oh, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN VLK: Well, Ellen, I
want to get to you, actually,
about your character,
too, Marlin.
Marlin's back.
And we have the new voice of
Nemo right back there, Hayden.
Say hello to everyone.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Hayden.
ANDREW STANTON:
Hayden's actually 30.
She plays a really
good 9-year-old.
HAYDEN ROLENCE: Wait,
you guys didn't know yet?
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN VLK: Albert,
your character, Marlin,
is back, obviously.
And it's interesting because
it was really, really great
to see you now have a
completely different dynamic
with your son, Nemo.
And now Marlin is
much more protective
over Dory, who wants
to go find her family.
So can you talk a
little bit about where
Marlin is at the stage?
ALBERT BROOKS: Well, I
know he doesn't agree,
but I thought that Marlin
was in love with Dory.
I mean it.
I just figured
that, you know, he--
ANDREW STANTON: Whatever
makes the scenes work for you.
ALBERT BROOKS:
Marlin's lonely and he
hadn't found anyone else.
And she's lovely and,
you know, why not?
EUGENE LEVY: I think we
have the next sequel.
TY BURRELL: Yeah, I
was just going to say,
there's your third.
[LAUGHTER]
ALBERT BROOKS: But you
know, it was great.
Hayden's terrific.
Alexander Gould, who played
the first one, he's 42.
So I actually was
in "Weeds" with him.
After he was Nemo, I played
his grandfather in "Weeds."
So that was sort of interesting
talking about pot with Nemo,
you know.
But Hayden's wonderful.
And you know, like a
modern divorced family,
here's a new kid.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN VLK: There we go.
It's going great.
So Ty and Kaitlin, you guys
play new characters in the film.
So we have Bailey, which
is your character, Ty,
and then Destiny.
So tell us about
your characters.
KAITLIN OLSON: We're buddies.
TY BURRELL: Yeah.
Basically, Bailey
and Destiny are
two people that Dory enlists
to help her find her folks.
People.
They're two people dressed in
whale and whale shark costumes.
KAITLIN OLSON: Yeah, it's
like an abstract kind
of a thing we were doing.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Did you
dress in whale costumes
when you recorded this?
KAITLIN OLSON: Yeah.
ELLEN DEGENERES: You
didn't need to do that.
TY BURRELL: We're the only
live action part of this movie.
It was exhausting.
ELLEN DEGENERES: You
must have been so hot.
KAITLIN OLSON: Yeah,
it was really hot.
Yeah, you're-- Bailey's a big
beluga whale and Destiny is
a giant whale shark.
And they're kind of a
brother-sister relationship,
they get on each other's nerves.
But they're very sweet and they
end up trying to help Dory out.
KEVIN VLK: Great.
And We have an
exclusive clip we're
going to play here in just
a few minutes with your two
characters, so we'll bring
that up here in a little bit.
But Ellen, you know,
you're returning
to the character of Dory.
It's a really, really
emotional story
about her trying to
find her parents.
So you know, when you
first read the script,
was there anything that you were
able to bring to the script,
or tell Andrew, I'm looking
for this in the character
or I want to go this direction?
ELLEN DEGENERES: No.
I mean, this guy's a genius.
I'm not going to tell him
how to write a script.
I mean, when I was in the
room, I changed a lot.
But I--
ANDREW STANTON: Yeah.
ELLEN DEGENERES: No.
But you know, that's
what's great about it.
The script is
fantastic-- the script is
what it is-- but it's
open and free enough
that you do 50 takes and you
just do whatever you want to do
and he chooses-- they
choose-- whatever
turns out to be the best one.
So--
ALBERT BROOKS: It's
always the first.
ANDREW STANTON:
But you know, it's
four years writing this thing.
I mean, we're doing-- there was
over 10 drafts of this story
done over that time.
And they know that while
we're working with them.
And you also adapt to the
actors once they're cast.
So I'm learning just
as much from them
and we're rewriting to
play to their strengths
so that it's like, hopefully,
comfortable shoes, almost.
And it becomes a little
symbiotic at a point.
KEVIN VLK: And Eugene,
you play Charlie--
EUGENE LEVY: Yes,
that's correct.
KEVIN VLK: --the father of Dory.
EUGENE LEVY: Yeah.
KEVIN VLK: So what can
you tell us about Charlie?
EUGENE LEVY: Well, it
was exciting to play
a dad who has a child not
doing strange things with pies.
That was a big plus for me.
TY BURRELL: That was,
like, your first question.
EUGENE LEVY: Yeah, right.
Yes.
Does Dory eat baked goods?
No, I-- no, it was kind of a--
it was a very charming-- well,
I was just honored to be
included in this thing.
No question about that.
And playing a dad,
you know, of a child
who is kind of memory
impaired, so to speak.
You know, it's kind of a
very funny, very amusing.
And there's something very
heartfelt about playing
a dad whose child
is off somewhere,
you don't know what
happened, and you know,
will they ever be able to--
how will they function?
Because she has no
memory-- short-term memory.
So you know, it was interesting
and complicated and fun and
exciting.
KEVIN VLK: I mean, that's
a real powerful part, too.
And Hayden, I'll get
right back to you.
But Andrew and
Lindsey, when you're
creating this story
about-- you use very much
a comedic effect
in "Finding Nemo,"
where you have Dory's character
with short-term memory loss.
That's a real
disability in life.
And you really, really
hit it home in this film.
So was that-- I mean,
because she's really
struggling with it.
You see it in the
beginning of the film,
you see it throughout.
So was that a point that you
really wanted to drive home?
ANDREW STANTON: Well,
she's the main character.
Once you have a main
character, there
has to be more depth to them.
And you, sadly,
are sort of forced
into a bit of a
straight man role
when you're in the
main character role.
The thing that was
always great about Dory
was that I always knew
that tragic side of her.
That was always-- I
always knew her optimism
and her caregiving
and her can-do spirit
was somewhat her armor
to protect herself
from this sense of loss she had.
So it was just sort of
flipping that on this film.
ELLEN DEGENERES:
It was great, too,
because I remember the day
that there was the scene where
I had to explain what
short-term memory loss was,
and how to explain it.
And that was one of the
times that I could just go--
ANDREW STANTON: Yeah.
ELLEN DEGENERES: --and
talk about what it-- how
to explain it to someone.
LINDSEY COLLINS: It was
funny and heartbreaking--
ANDREW STANTON:
--at the same time.
LINDSEY COLLINS:
And I think that's kind
of what the movie really
leans into on this one.
That it's charming,
and that is Dory.
And we were always
trying to walk
that line between the charm
that was Dory and that
is Ellen and then also the
kind of tragedy, really, of it.
And making sure that
we never leaned too far
one way or the other
so that we felt like it
was being really true
to this character.
KEVIN VLK: It was
a delicate balance.
I mean, that's what it was.
Like, in the beginning
of the movie,
you first-- your initial
reaction is the laugh.
It's like, oh, that's Dory.
And then it starts getting
deeper and you're like, oh god.
And like it's really,
really intense.
So Hayden, the
new voice of Nemo.
Pretty exciting-- from
my hometown of Chicago.
So welcome here to California.
So what was it like to be Nemo?
HAYDEN ROLENCE:
It's very fun being
able to pretend that I'm
just a cute, little fish
and I'm not just me.
I actually get to
pretend that I'm
something that's a very good
idea and very fun to do.
KEVIN VLK: You're
wonderful in it.
It's crazy.
When I was watching
it, I actually
didn't realize at first--
from the trailers--
that they got a new voice.
And I was like, well,
of course they did.
It's 13 years later.
And you pull-- you
sound exactly like him.
It's great.
You did a wonderful job.
ELLEN DEGENERES: He's like
the Darrin of "Bewitched."
You know, like, he had to be
as good as the original Darrin
and it's really tough.
KEVIN VLK: A lot
of this takes place
in a marine, which is a great
thing because in "Finding
Nemo," you see the characters
going through open water
and oceans and
everything, and you
have different environments.
But now you're in
a marine institute.
And for you, Lindsey and
Andrew, when you guys are there,
there's a lot of creative
ways of how the characters get
around the park.
But what was one of the
most complicated scenes--
as a producer, Lindsey,
you're just like, really?
LINDSEY COLLINS: I
think, honestly, it
was when Andrew came
and was like, so we've
come up with this new
character and he's an octopus.
And I said, I'm sorry, what?
And he said, he's an octopus.
Well, he's a septopus, so
you get one less tentacle.
He is-- Hank, the
octopus, no doubt,
is the hardest character,
I think, anybody at Pixar
has ever done.
And took two years.
I mean, normally, our
characters take nine months,
start to finish.
And this took two-- he took two
and a half years just to build
and rig.
And so that was one
where I was like, really?
Does it have to be an octopus?
Could you maybe not?
Maybe turtle?
ANDREW STANTON: No.
LINDSEY COLLINS: No.
ANDREW STANTON:
Already have that.
LINDSEY COLLINS:
Something plastic?
ANDREW STANTON: The first shot
took six months to animate.
And we were, we're never going
to get finished at this rate.
But fortunately, everybody
got smarter and faster.
KEVIN VLK: And what
environments were some
of the most complicated ones?
Because you see them in
pipes and different tanks.
LINDSEY COLLINS: It's
definitely the glass.
If you watch "Finding
Nemo," you'll
notice that there was,
like, only three shots,
I think, where we
allowed Andrew to put
the camera in the corner of
the tank of the dentist office.
And it's because of the
reflection and refraction.
I'm talking to people
at Google and YouTube
so I feel like I'm in my
people, you understand me.
And it's really hard.
I mean, we intentionally didn't
do that because the computer
couldn't do it and we had
to direct it and fake it--
all the lighting.
And so the new renderer
actually allowed
us to do much, much more.
And we took full
advantage of it.
ANDREW STANTON: So
we do it everywhere.
We basically-- he
did it everywhere.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Coffee pots.
LINDSEY COLLINS: Yes.
Every possible container has
glass and reflection in it.
KEVIN VLK: I gotcha.
An so are there
any-- Andrew, what
I loved was-- I remember
watching-- I'm a huge Pixar
fan, animation fan-- and I loved
watching, in the first one,
some of the making of it.
And you kind of tacked
onto this flashback thing
in the first
"Finding Nemo," where
you want to do flashbacks and
tell the story through that.
And it's a great plot
device that you used here
throughout the movie, as
well, to tell Dory's story.
Was that something
you immediately
knew that you wanted to do
or did that come organically?
ANDREW STANTON: Oh, that
is an 11th hour idea that
saved our butts on this movie.
We came up with it last fall.
But a lot of people don't know
"Nemo" didn't come together
till the last six
or eight months.
All the pieces
were there, we just
didn't have them lined right.
And so I feel like this movie's
in good hands in a weird way
because it did the same pattern.
But yeah, the first
movie-- all that tragedy
you see at the beginning of
"Finding Nemo," all that loss,
was actually flashbacks
that were doled out.
And it just didn't work, you
didn't sympathize with Marlin.
But once we saw his
tragedy at the front--
we moved it all to the front--
and suddenly, all the lines
we'd always had played fine.
Everybody empathized with him.
And then this was the reverse.
We had too much
information at the front.
And then when we
doled it out and made
it memories that Dory has
and is triggered as she goes,
it became like the inverse
of the first movie.
And it just felt right.
It was Jason Bourne
style, it was great.
ALBERT BROOKS: You can take
that into your own life.
Start every conversation
with your saddest story.
ANDREW STANTON: It works.
KEVIN VLK: And so
now, we're going
to cue an exclusive clip
here from "Finding Dory,"
so let's cue it up.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Can you please keep
it down over there?
My head hurts.
-Who's that?
-That's my neighbor, Bailey.
He was brought in
with a head injury.
-I know you're talking
about me, Destiny.
-He thinks he can't
use his echolocation,
but I've overheard
the doctor's talking.
-I'm right here.
-There's not a thing
wrong with him.
-I hear every word
you're saying about me.
-What's echolocation?
-Well, Bailey's head is
supposed to put out a call
and the echo helps him
find objects far away.
Oh, but apparently,
he's still healing.
-Now I know you're
talking about me.
I really can't echolocate.
-I cannot have this
conversation again.
I just can't.
-I hit my head very
hard out there.
See how swollen it is?
-Your head is
supposed to be big.
You're a beluga.
[END PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN VLK: So Ty
and Kaitlin, those
are your guys' characters--
Bailey and Destiny.
Did you guys record
it all together
to get some of the
dynamic and improv?
TY BURRELL: We did.
That was--
KAITLIN OLSON: That was fun.
We got to do two
or three together.
You know, mostly
you're just in there
by yourself with these guys.
TY BURRELL: Right.
ANDREW STANTON: Again.
KAITLIN OLSON: But we got
to do a couple together
and it was really fun.
Because we're actors, we're used
to working with-- these guys,
by the way, are amazing.
TY BURRELL: They're too
smart for us, though.
It's much-- I'm always look--
KAITLIN OLSON: Yeah, it's
better to work with dumb people.
TY BURRELL: Yeah.
KAITLIN OLSON: Yeah.
TY BURRELL: She was looking
for an idiot and she found one.
KAITLIN OLSON: That's right.
It makes me more comfortable.
It makes me feel smarter.
TY BURRELL: Yeah, that was
actually-- that was new for me.
I haven't done a
ton of animation,
but the chance to go in and
be in the room with, well,
Kaitlin, in particular,
who's so funny.
The whole process
is so collaborative.
Obviously, we're
not really tinkering
with any of the major writing.
But these guys
are just so smart.
And so much changes
as you're doing it
that when we were able to do
it together, it really felt--
KAITLIN OLSON: Yeah,
just the freedom
to play around a little bit
and see what else was there.
TY BURRELL: Yeah.
KEVIN VLK: It's great.
We're going to bring up one
of our YouTube top creators,
sWooZie, to ask some
questions that he got
from our social media handle.
So let's bring him up.
[APPLAUSE]
SWOOZIE: Hi.
Check, check.
How's it going, guys?
KAITLIN OLSON: Hi.
TY BURRELL: Good.
SWOOZIE: So we asked a lot
of our YouTube subscribers
and the YouTube peoples
out there some questions.
And a lot of them are
coming toward you, Andrew.
They want to know how you
go about selecting voices
for your movies.
ANDREW STANTON: Oh, well,
everybody knows the term
that the camera loves them.
They're very photogenic.
But I like to say
there's a term where
the microphone loves them.
There are people that just
have voices that you can just
hang a character on.
And sitting in front of you are
five amazing examples-- or six,
I'm sorry.
I can't count today.
Six examples--
TY BURRELL: Was I the one
you weren't thinking of?
ANDREW STANTON: Yeah, I
wasn't thinking of you.
LINDSEY COLLINS: The microphone
does not love you, Ty.
I'm sorry.
TY BURRELL: There are five
people in front of you.
ANDREW STANTON: No, four.
No, wait a minute.
Three.
LINDSEY COLLINS: I'm not
going to say which is--
TY BURRELL: One guy who
just tries super hard.
[LAUGHTER]
He's just a hard working guy.
ANDREW STANTON: But it's true.
Like, when you want to-- I
started out as an animator,
so I really recognize when
you hear a voice that you just
can't help but project
a character on.
You can't help want
to see acting from out
of a different character.
And so you end up with
these lists sometimes.
Ellen, herself, was
somebody I wasn't thinking
of at the time when I was really
in the early days of writing
on "Finding Nemo," and
then I heard her off
of a television set and
boom, it suddenly matched.
I'd been a fan of
Albert's ever since I
can remember, going
to all of his movies
and listening to
his comedy albums.
And so I was waiting for the
right role to fall for that.
And then, Kaitlin--
same thing-- I'd
sort of been a fan
of her voice, and Ty.
And Hayden, I discovered.
And Eugene-- all
these are people
that I've just been fans
of hearing and I just go,
they would be perfect.
But you're just waiting
for the right character
that you're coming up with and
hope that somebody else hasn't
grabbed them before you do.
SWOOZIE: That's
another thing, too.
On YouTube, a lot of us are
one-man production teams
and a lot of us do animation.
So there's a lot of people
wondering how do we start off?
Anybody that wants
to be involved
with animation, the process.
Just out the gate,
what would you
recommend, as far as programs,
for anybody starting out?
ANDREW STANTON:
God, I don't know.
I mean, I'm too old now.
I don't know.
I started out with
pencil and paper.
I still use pencil and paper.
I don't know if anybody
knows what that is, but.
SWOOZIE: Old school,
like Stone Age stuff.
ANDREW STANTON: All I
can say is it's so easy.
I mean, now you can make
a movie in your house.
I had to steal stuff when
I did it to get movies
made in my backyard and stuff.
So I'd just say, do it.
Grab whatever you can and do it.
There's nothing stopping
you, so just do it.
SWOOZIE: This one
was popping up a lot.
We can go on to-- all right.
What about other
animated Disney films--
if you could be in any of those
other animated Disney films,
what movie would
you want to be in?
KAITLIN OLSON: I'm a
huge fan of all the Pixar
movies and particularly
all of Andrew's movies.
I was a huge fan of "WALL-E"
and all the "Toy Stories."
Those were just-- I watched
those before I had kids
and then my little
boys love those movies.
So those are the ones
that are always on.
And so when I got
the call about this,
I was like, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't care what
I'm playing, but yes.
Whatever.
ALBERT BROOKS: I'd like
to give the candlestick
a go in "Beauty and the Beast."
ANDREW STANTON: Nice.
Even the Broadway version?
ALBERT BROOKS: No.
Not matinees.
SWOOZIE: What about you, Hayden?
Any other movie--
"Aladdin," "Lion King,"
any of those that
you'd want to be in?
HAYDEN ROLENCE: I
don't really know
if I'd want to be in any
other movie besides this one.
SWOOZIE: Good answer.
LINDSEY COLLINS: Good answer.
That's the answer.
SWOOZIE: Your check
is in the mail.
LINDSEY COLLINS: You win.
SWOOZIE: Bonus.
Ellen, what about you?
ELLEN DEGENERES: Same answer.
I would never--
SWOOZIE: This is the one.
ELLEN DEGENERES: I thought Dory
was great in "Finding Nemo."
Joy in "Inside Out"
would have been fun.
I liked Joy.
I mean, I'm very
happy being Dory.
Eugene, anybody?
EUGENE LEVY: No,
I-- the thing of it
is, really, these pictures--
all the Pixar animations--
are so incredibly great.
And the process is
so much fun to do.
I mean, I don't know
if anybody really
understands exactly what you
do when you're in a studio,
but it's really quite amazing.
And when you get to work
with incredibly talented,
genius people here,
where you kind of just
give a line and they-- as you're
giving the line in the scene--
they kind of know--
they're making changes
as they're going.
Try it this way,
try it this way.
And it's all happening
in milliseconds.
And it's an incredibly
exciting way to work because--
ANDREW STANTON: You also got
to act with Diane Keaton,
so that's probably
why he's on a high.
EUGENE LEVY: I know, my
wife isn't here today.
That was kind of fun, too.
But yeah, I would say
it's a really fun way
to work, doing animated films.
And when the scripts
and the stories
are as exciting
as "Finding Dory,"
then you consider
yourself very lucky.
SWOOZIE: OK.
Awesome.
That's all the time
I have for you guys.
We have some crowd
questions later,
but I'm going to
toss it back here.
Thanks so much for
your time, guys.
ALL: Thank you.
LINDSEY COLLINS: Nice t-shirt.
KEVIN VLK: Thank you, sWooZie.
We're going to take
some audience questions.
I think they're going
to start lining up here.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Wait, can you hear me?
You can hear me.
I kind of want to ask
a question of everyone,
but I'm going to focus on Dory.
So don't be offended.
It's all good, you're all cool.
My question to you
is in "Finding Dory,"
one of the mantras for me
was "just keep swimming,"
which is-- I'm a plus-sized
health and fitness motivator,
so I help women like me start
and re-engage in fitness.
So to me, it's about
the journey-- embracing
the journey-- just keep moving.
No matter what
happens, just keep
going while loving you are
and the body you're in.
So what I'd be
curious to know is
what is your life lesson
coming out of "Finding Dory"?
Did you have that moment-- that
"just keep swimming" moment--
that really stood out to you?
ELLEN DEGENERES: Well, my life
is-- that's my motto, as well.
AUDIENCE: No, it's my motto.
ELLEN DEGENERES: OK, it's yours.
I'm now--
AUDIENCE: We'll share.
ELLEN DEGENERES: --so sorry
to now steal it from you.
Second lawsuit.
AUDIENCE: I'm aggressive.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Well, it
was kind of like my motto.
It wasn't completely my motto.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I think if
anyone knows my story,
it is-- I had to
just keep swimming.
My life has been a
lot of challenges
and a lot of different
curves and roadblocks.
And so I think that's
a great-- you know,
I didn't come up with
"just keep swimming,"
but it has turned out to be
something that a lot of people
can hold onto and
use in their life.
And so I would say
just everything.
I think I am so blessed
and lucky that that's
part of my character, that I get
to say, "just keep swimming,"
for whoever you are and
whatever you're going through.
AUDIENCE: Well,
thank you for that
because it's a big life changer.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I just wanted to know what
your favorite aspect of working
on this film has
been, whether it's
recording, fleshing out the
story, promoting it, et cetera?
Of anyone.
LINDSEY COLLINS: You've had
the big-- you've had, probably,
the most to choose from, yeah.
ANDREW STANTON:
Honestly, working
with the actors is
probably my favorite,
simply because they're
sitting in front of me.
No, it's actually
because it's the one
part of this process over four
years that's spontaneous--
where you're actually doing
a lot of give and take
in the moment and you're in the
now and you're just reacting.
And I find that so exciting.
I get very little of it
working in animated pictures,
so I'm pretty hungry for it
when we do these sessions.
I know they're
grueling, they're long.
These guys stand
around for four hours
and they're just
on the whole time.
So they're basically
doing a one-person show.
And a lot of them--
I know I've said
that it's the most tiring thing
they do simply because there's
no breaks built into it.
But it's pretty invigorating,
it's pretty exciting to me.
CHRISTINA CALPH: Hello,
I'm Christina Calph
from the channel
Bad Girl's Ball.
This question is for everyone.
A lot of people in the
audience, including myself,
are content creators
here at YouTube.
And I just would like to
ask you all what advice
you'd like to give us
with building our careers.
TY BURRELL: Get super lucky.
[LAUGHTER]
Get weirdly lucky.
CHRISTINA CALPH:
That's horrible advice.
Horrible advice.
TY BURRELL: I apologize.
ALBERT BROOKS:
Well, someone asked
a question earlier to
Andrew about how do you
animate something?
And you know, I would say
the answer's the same,
and that's a story.
You start with
that-- you start--
you're a content creator.
So you don't start
with the actors,
you don't start with the set,
you start with the story.
You start with the content.
And if you have
a great story, it
can fit 100 different
ways to tell it.
Animation, it can
fit live action.
So you know, think
of great stories.
Just stories that
you haven't heard.
I would say that's a
basis to start with.
ELLEN DEGENERES: I
would say authenticity.
I think whatever-- I think if
something's happened to you,
and the same thing that Albert's
saying-- if you have a story,
you're probably
not the only person
with that story, whatever it is.
And sometimes the
best stuff comes out
of the hardest stuff
and the worst stuff
that you've gone through.
So if you've actually
experienced something,
I don't think anybody should
hide any kind of truth.
So whatever you have witnessed
or experienced or gone through,
find a way to express that
and find a way to stay.
And I think people read
truth and authenticity.
And I think that's the
most important thing
for establishing anything.
ALBERT BROOKS: And even if
you don't have something,
you must have a horrible uncle.
CHRISTINA CALPH:
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I know a lot of you have
experience with improv
and just being
quick on your feet,
and I was wondering
how much room there
was for improvisation.
It seems like a lot, from
what you've been saying,
but how that
improvisation affects
the process and
the final product
and how it might be different
from other animated films,
as it was with "Finding Dory."
ALBERT BROOKS:
Well, I don't know
compared to-- other animated
films are different.
Some of "The Simpsons"
that I've done,
the whole thing was improv'ed.
There's always a
solid script here.
And the thing about Andrew is
that once he gets those words,
if you're willing
to keep going, he'll
take every word in the
English language out of you.
So by the end of the day,
you've given a lot of choices.
Hopefully, there are some
choices he didn't think of.
And then they have
to-- the thing
I'm most grateful for is I
don't have to listen back
to these recording sessions.
ANDREW STANTON: Exactly.
ALBERT BROOKS: Because after
9,000 takes, I just say,
you choose.
ANDREW STANTON: Every person
here-- there's at least one
or two lines, if
not more, that are
in the finished movie of
things that they came up
with on the set that I
would have never written.
ALBERT BROOKS:
But you know, it's
generally-- in
animated films-- I
think it's generally welcome
because it's at the stage where
it's still-- you're not
coming into a finished movie
where you have to fit the
exact words in a mouth.
So they, generally, if you
can do it, they welcome it.
AUDIENCE: This is a
question for Ellen and Dory.
How did you learn to
(IMITATING DORY) speak whale?
ELLEN DEGENERES: Well, that's
a very good, first of all.
[LAUGHTER]
I was in Hawaii and
there was a woman
who was staying in the house
next to the house that I
was renting.
And she was doing yoga--
like, crazy yoga on rocks--
and listening to whale sounds.
I didn't know you
could buy that record,
but there's a record that
just is whale sounds.
And I was listening to it and
it just was like the most--
the weirdest thing I'd
ever seen in my life.
And I just thought, a wave
is going to take her out any
minute and it didn't.
I kind of wanted it to
happen because it was just
so weird that she's
on her head on a rock.
And so anyway, I just knew
what a whale sounded like
and I didn't think I'd ever need
to use it in life, but I did.
ANDREW STANTON: I was so
scared to ask her this.
I thought, this is
going to be the thing.
This is going to be--
this is on "Nemo"--
this is going to be the
thing that makes her go, OK,
I'm done.
I'm not in this movie anymore.
I'm out.
And I'm like, would you
be willing to speak whale?
And she told me this
whole story right away.
And just went right into it.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Oh, I can
speak whale, all right.
I've been waiting.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's it.
And it's not easy.
I mean, you did it very well.
But if you have to
do it a lot, it's
very tough on your vocal chords.
You have to kind of warm up.
ANDREW STANTON: Kaitlin
had to do it a lot.
Because her
character's the reason
Dory knows how to speak whale.
KAITLIN OLSON: Yeah,
I did it a lot.
They'd look at me and
go, um, one last thing.
I'm like, oh, OK,
let's just do it.
Get me some tea.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hello, my
question is for Ellen.
What was the
craziest moment that
happened on set when recording
the movie "Finding Dory"?
ELLEN DEGENERES:
The craziest moment?
I don't know if there
was a crazy moment, but--
ANDREW STANTON:
Your back went out.
LINDSEY COLLINS: You
couldn't even stand.
Your back went out.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Oh, I
don't even remember that.
We did this for three
years, so what happened?
ANDREW STANTON: You
came in like this.
LINDSEY COLLINS: When you came
in, you couldn't stand up.
It was like right before
you came into the session
and you still had to do a
four-hour session with us.
And we were like, we're really
sorry, could you do one more?
ELLEN DEGENERES: That's right.
That's-- well, I don't
know if it was crazy.
It was sad.
LINDSEY COLLINS: Sad.
Sad.
ELLEN DEGENERES: It's
one of the saddest.
Do you want a sad
moment or a crazy?
Yeah.
I forgot.
And then I literally--
I had to still do it.
ALBERT BROOKS:
Another crazy moment
where you got in that
horrible accident.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Yeah,
remember that time when I was--
ANDREW STANTON: So crazy.
LINDSEY COLLINS:
It was so crazy.
Crazy Ellen.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Yeah.
I was going to
say-- this is just
an excuse to complain about it.
They-- because Dory is
always either left behind
or catching up to people.
So there's a lot of
hyperventilating,
like breathing really just--
(HYPERVENTILATING) guys,
it's that or it's
like, scream-- ah!
A lot of those.
And you'd think
that once-- I just
did that-- you could use that
throughout the whole film,
right?
But I had to do it all the time.
I had to-- and I was
just like, don't you
really have the
(PANTING) already?
So there was a lot of that.
And when you see this film, and
you should see it many times,
you will see that I don't do
it that often in the film.
And I don't know why
he needed me to--
LINDSEY COLLINS: That
was your first comment.
That was like-- Ellen was
like, I really loved it.
Where was all the gasping
and hyperventilating?
Literally, that was
her first question
right out of her mouth.
Where is it?
ALBERT BROOKS: It's in the toys.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Yeah.
I see.
That's how they get you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Who came up with the idea for
Sia to cover "Unforgettable"
and how did that all come about?
LINDSEY COLLINS: Oh, gosh.
ANDREW STANTON: I
don't know who exactly.
LINDSEY COLLINS: Well, you
always wanted the song.
That was always.
ANDREW STANTON: I said they
got to have one syllable.
That's the only
thing I care about.
One syllable.
ELLEN DEGENERES:
And we don't want
to know what she looks like.
LINDSEY COLLINS: No, but
the song was always there.
Like, you always wanted that
song at the end of the movie.
And we knew it was
going to be covered.
We didn't want the
original, we wanted it--
ANDREW STANTON: Robbie
Robertson-- Robertson-- Robbie
Williams had actually
covered "Beyond the Sea"
on the first movie.
And so I wanted it to
feel like that same sort
of complementary modern day
singer plus an old classic.
And Sia was pretty much
on the top of the list.
LINDSEY COLLINS: And then
we were talking to you,
and we were like,
come on, Ellen.
ELLEN DEGENERES:
I was in a session
and they said the song is
going to be "Unforgettable"
and they said we're
thinking of Sia.
And I got my phone out--
LINDSEY COLLINS: Seriously.
She was like, let's see how
fast we can make this happen.
ELLEN DEGENERES:
I said right now.
And so I texted her and she
was like, are you kidding me?
Of course.
I would love to do that.
So it was like that quick.
She just was so excited.
LINDSEY COLLINS: Turns out,
when you know Ellen Degeneres--
ANDREW STANTON: Good to
be a friend of Ellen.
LINDSEY COLLINS: Can
happen pretty quickly.
TY BURRELL: I was texting
with Sia, too, and she never--
KAITLIN OLSON: That's the thing
is she was texting with me when
she got that text.
And I was like, all right,
go, Ellen needs you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KEVIN VLK: Thank you, guys.
So a couple things
for the audience, too.
Google also partnered
with Pixar and Disney
to basically give you guys
a lot of really cool content
on the knowledge panel.
If you type in "Finding
Dory" on Google search,
you'll see over on
the right-hand side
in the knowledge panel,
there's a whole bunch of stuff
that Disney's been
doing-- trailers and gifts
and a whole bunch of stuff.
It's been really cool stuff.
Thank you guys so much
for providing that.
You guys probably didn't
know, but it's there.
And now you guys know.
So check that out.
Also, to celebrate
"Finding Dory,"
and today being
World Oceans Day,
everyone's tuning in just to
help our friends of the sea,
so there's a donate button
in the Livestream links
you'll see there.
And after this, as well, to the
Wildlife Conservation Society--
ALBERT BROOKS: Oh, I thought you
literally had friends at sea,
I was scared.
KEVIN VLK: Friends in the sea.
Yeah.
To help save rays,
sharks, and other wildlife
in the wild places
across the globe.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
It's a great thing Disney is
doing if you guys look that up.
And so what we're
going to do here
is going to be
something pretty cool
and you guys are all
going to be involved.
You guys ready?
We're going to take a shelfie.
Yeah, terrible pun, I know.
So sWooZie, come on up here.
What we're going to is, guys,
in your seats, just stand up,
don't crowd the stage.
We're going to take
the cast, we're
going to stand right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
There we go.
Thank you guys so much.
So we're wrapping up here, guys.
"Finding Dory" is going to
be in theaters June 17th,
so just a couple weeks.
So check it out and thank you
guys so much for being here.
[APPLAUSE]